imagine if trump and desantis are like
look man
if there's one time ever where you and i
let's just do this together i'll go one
term you take two terms
and let's go run together do you think
this unifies trump and desantis at all
i think it has to but i actually there
was a really interesting um
pairing that i saw suggested the other
day was uh donald trump and marjorie
taylor green
was i i thought was now i'm not a big
fan of mtg but but
you said something the other day that
desantis and trump are both type a
personalities
i don't know first of all i don't think
ron desantis would make the mistake of
running against trump at a primary i
think he knows exactly what would happen
i think he looks at ted cruz your your
wife looks like a dog and like he he
knows that i don't think there's any way
ronda sanchez yeah i'm not asking i'm
not asking marjorie i'm i'm asking
does this because here's the big concern
is those two going up against each other
right
the way the left is gonna do it is
divide and conquer you gotta pin those
two against each other right you have to
do that bingo it has to be strategic
does this unify those two to say we're
both alphas but let's do this together
for four years i think it unifies them
but i don't think it puts them together
i i think i really think actually that
desantis stays in as governor of florida
he stays in florida and trump picks
another solid running mate i i as as
nice as it would be and i think as
powerful as it would be i don't see that
happening
i wonder because what what purpose does
it serve what purpose does it serve to
remove ron desantis as the strongest
governor in the nation of the strongest
state in the nation right now to put him
as the vice president and then who would
backfill him who would backfill ron
desantis and who how can we guarantee
that who backfills ronda santa's keeps
florida as it is florida is a beacon
right now don't think selfishly think if
you lived in tennessee forget about fl
forget about florida think you're living
in idaho you're not living in florida
think america more than you think about
the state we're living in today does
this bring those two together
it should
i think it should i think it won't
because in my concept desantis is
another one who is
playing the game of political strategy
in his career his individual career has
a you know he's taken a lot of risks put
his neck on the line on principle and i
respect that i respect
many of the things ron desantis has done
in a time of crisis he held the breach
and that's that's something to be that's
commendable
but
um
to what degree must be measured against
the circumstance we're in
and if he really believes that we're
under attack the way he says he does if
he really if all of these people donald
trump too if all of these people really
believe that america's existence with
our foundational values and ideas
is is facing the existential threat that
it does all of them have to put their
ego aside and their ambitions that's
something a good christian faith would
give them
it's not about me
it's not about me running at 24. it's
about what's best right now for we the
people
and for we the people a desantis trump
ticket would say
that all of the tangential political
ancillary
strategy and
trajectories and me and 24 28 none of
that matters
we're going to stand side by side based
on sacred honor
but they're going to have trouble coming
to that because neither one of them
think that way and and their in their
behavior up until this point has proved
that they think along the lines of
political strategy that's part of the
reason why trump endorsed a bunch of
candidates who don't even really who
aren't really america first but he did
it
and they end up winning i know yeah and
the maga people are raising but they're
like i mean i'm seeing it on the
grassroots level in the you know trump
is a strategist trump is not uh yeah
he's he's not at your level of
his his method of getting things done is
very different than the way you get it
done and and to my point though his
people betrayed him the first time and
he hasn't learned yet and i pray at
night
that going into this next election cycle
he will have a change of heart and mind
because his people betrayed him when you
think strategy too much sometimes
you're too smart for your own good yeah
but people so so then what jesus was uh
not the his people betrayed him yes so
that that is part of the game the part
of the game is betrayal but trailer is
part of the level you're competing at
you you're not going to be able to uh uh
stop a trail no man it happens that the
higher you move up the more it's going
to hurt but it's going to happen no
doubt so he's he's playing at a
different level and it's very normal for
that i i understand the way i'm
explaining it doesn't make sense like
what do you mean it's supposed to be
normal it's very normal at that level
and i'm look my criticism is just to
because
most of the criticism against me is
well you started off you know leading
these peaceful protests for george floyd
which were really more about
corporatocracy not about racism and
politics
but um it was framed that way and now
they go well now you're just a show for
donald trump or the far right i'm like
no i mean there's criticism to go around
yeah um and donald trump has a fair
share that he should reasonably get um
but you're right at that level just like
i said about him picking the the proper
even the attorney general bill barr was
probably a bad pick
um but but he trusted him uh and he came
up short uh and and we're all gonna do
that so if you like this clip and you
want to watch another one click right
here and if you want to watch the entire
podcast click right here
[Music]